friends
so
um this is a new describe uh work
um it's based on a series of papers
um variously let's joined with my
student highlight my longtime
collaborator at bgu Ronnie Stern his
student argaman and recently uh this new
guy Enrico
uh and so the problem
um is grounded in AI
uh as you might know
I might be able to tell and I don't
assume that you have a lot of
familiarity with these problems
so as soon as my clicker works
we'll get started
do it
all right
okay let's try that again
welcome to everybody
Okay so
I guess I'm going to be clicking from
here now
probably
because the clicker was working
there you go thank you
all right so
right so you know first we'll uh Define
the problems uh we'll give a basic
algorithm and then we'll get into the
maybe meteor uh questions about you know
learnability that start to get um touch
like more complexity aspects of the
problem
so as I said it's motivated from some um
AI concerns right where
um you have some sort of a real world
problem you know I want trucks to take
these packages from these locations to
those locations
which gets modeled in some formal
description language like pddl
okay which says you know what I can do
in this world is I can move the trucks
from point A to point B the truck can
pick up packages and so on
uh that formal description of the uh you
know what you can do in the model is
pass to an algorithm a planner which you
know given some start State and some set
of desired conditions like maybe I want
the package to be at C right gives a
sequence of these actions
um
that is supposed to get me from wherever
I started to some sort of a state where
the packages at sea or whatever it was
that I wanted
so
um we often or the simplest uh model for
these planning domains a classic thing
is called strips which if you took an AI
Class A long time ago you probably saw
okay so in strips the domains are given
by a set of actions and a set of fluents
those are relations but
um you know they change value over time
so really it's that you've got a family
of these things indexed by what time
step you're on
both the actions and the fluence are
going to be parameterized by a fixed set
of typed arguments right so the move
action uh has arguments of type truck
location location at as type uh truck
and location and so on
so an action model describes
preconditions and effects for the
actions
so in strips a precondition is just a
conjunction of literals uh written on
those fluents
and then the effects are a set of
literals written on the fluids and the
interpretation of this is essentially
that in order to take the action that
precondition had to hold at the current
step and after I take the action the
effects will hold at the next step
and so we're going to assume that the in
the action model uh those variables that
are you know appearing are action
parameters
as they are here right so maybe you know
if move was a uh action then at in the
preconditions OR effects right you know
would have its arguments bound to one of
these three
parameters
all right uh so a problem in strips is
given by a set of objects some sort of
initial State and a goal right so uh
grounded fluence are fluence bound to
objects from that set a state in these
problems is a truths values for those
ground influence
and the goal is a conjunction uh written
over the ground influence and so a plan
is just a sequence of actions now bound
to the objects in the domain right so
grounded actions
uh that are supposed to transform
my start State into one that satisfies
the goal conjunction
so precisely uh the you know the way
that the problem evolves as you take
actions is given by the strips axioms
okay so right a trajectory you're
getting trajectories in these problems
right or sequences of States
um so
binding the fluence to all the possible
objects and giving truce values to those
objects
um and the actions that you take in a
plan are going to be related to that
sequence of states by these strips
axioms so for every triple like this
right so at time T minus one there's a
state there's an action at time T giving
you a new state at time T we're
guaranteed that
the precondition of that action had to
be satisfied in that previous state
the each effect literal of that action
is satisfied in the post state
and each literal that wasn't one of the
effects uh and was satisfied in the
pre-state remain satisfied in the post
State that's called the frame Axiom okay
so between these they completely
determine uh which literals are true and
which are false in that post state
and so yeah solution to a planning
problem is a plan a sequence of grounded
actions that takes the start state to
something that satisfies the goal and
um I'll often refer to those States as
pre and post
all right so in domain independent
planning
um you're supposed to be able to write
many different real world planning
problems in these formal languages and
the problem that we want to face here is
how do we get these formal descriptions
of these World models
so a naive approach to doing this with
machine learning would be to just treat
it as a supervised learning problem
so you know these actions look like
they're just functions mapping
pre-states to post States so let me just
try to treat that as a supervised
learning problem like you know it's
classic pack learning
and
um the basic problem that happens here
is distribution shift right so if I'm
using a new sequence of actions that I
haven't seen previously I'm going to get
to some Distribution on states that
looks very much unlike whatever I saw
previously you know in particular if I'm
trying to reach a new goal State that's
unlike those that I've seen before
there's no way I can use any kind of a
nice packed learning style guarantee to
say anything about that distribution
that I hadn't seen before
um and in particular the planner can
exploit like errors in the model okay to
try to drive me towards places where
um you know maybe things look better
than they should okay and the other
problem is that I can't learn these
preconditions they're always true in
these trajectories that I get so the
always true thing looks like it should
be an okay precondition but it is
um so you know there's been work on
learning planning models okay uh but
basically in summary these prior Works
although they'll produce for you some
sort of a model like a formal domain
description they don't really have
guarantees about correctness and it is
possible to get incorrect models from
them
um and then you know I guess maybe the
elephant in the room is reinforcement
learning probably everybody's heard of
it
um you know it's like you take an action
and then somebody tells you how good or
bad that action was and then you want to
optimize the sum of those rewards over
time okay
so you know in all these
um problems right what happens is you
get a sequence of observations uh maybe
you acted in the world or maybe somebody
gave you some some set of observations
of people acting which is past your
learning algorithm that's supposed to
produce that formal domain description
and now you know especially in
reinforcement learning uh the the
learner gets to choose to make actions
in the world right so some trial and
error
um you know the the the the acting and
learning thing is sort of tightly
integrated in reinforcement learning
um and also in these other other models
you know whenever you would get an error
from executing a plan then okay you know
throw that
um you know example trajectory into the
pool and see what we get next
but as a result uh these methods are not
safe what does that mean well you know
supposing I want to
um use these methods to train my robot
car you know I'd really like real data
you know because like that's going to
tell me how the world actually behaves
but it might not be so good right and
you know uh it says oh okay you know you
didn't like that okay uh well maybe I
came at the wrong angle I don't know you
know it could take a lot of Trials
um especially for reinforcement learning
uh to actually come up with a good
policy okay and that's that's risky okay
so we don't like that so much so we want
to get rid of these exploration actions
um
and this is actually very similar to uh
a model called offline reinforcement
learning which is sort of a cousin of
what we're going to consider here and
again the principle is that
because exploration is unsafe let's just
give trajectories that were collected by
some sort of an expert you know maybe a
human driving the car
and based on that try to learn uh what's
acceptable and what's not okay so
there's a slightly more subtle
distinction between what we're doing
with these planning models and
reinforcement learning
um basically a high level you know uh
we'll have higher level uh problems
versus what reinforcement learning looks
at which is very low level
um reinforcement learning optimizes a
fixed reward function whereas we'll get
some sort of a reusable model uh
reinforcement learning tends to use more
data than planning models do but it's
because we're making stronger structural
assumptions where some reinforcement
learning you just give it sensor data uh
and Resco okay so all right
so we want to do this um learning just
from trajectories that somebody
collected for us okay and we want to be
sure that the thing that we get out is
correct that's that's roughly our notion
of safety
so how do we do that
um a naive approach might be to try to
learn an exact description of what
happens in in this domain okay just say
I want you know I want these functions
to be correct everywhere
and that doesn't work because these
example trajectories I get would often
be impossible it would not be possible
to completely identify that domain model
right you know for example if it just
happened that some fluent was always
true whenever I took an action in that
in that training set
I have no way of telling if that action
would have made that fluent true
so I don't know if that's an effect of
the action so if I ever tried to use
that action in some some state where
um the fluent was false then okay like I
wouldn't know what would happen
uh and so then I would just get for a
trivial reason that that the learning
problem was impossible
okay so what we've got in this problem
to work with is that
um training and testing examples are
drawn from the same distribution and in
planning that's going to mean that it's
a distribution over planning problems
right so start States in goal States
yeah
one's in between
uh is not necessarily coming from any
nice fixed distribution although I do
assume that I'm getting examples of
trajectories uh executing plans solving
problems from D but I don't assume that
there was any kind of a nice function
that uh produced these trajectories I
don't assume that there's some
whatever you know simple class of linear
functions or whatever that takes a
planning problem and gives you a
trajectory
but I do assume that future problems
that I want to solve are also going to
be drawn from this same distribution
over problems
so this is this is the basic setup for
the learning problem that I'm going to
face
and so you know to summarize I'm given
the set of trajectories for problems
sampled from that distribution
and I'm not given what the effects and
preconditions of the actions are that's
the action model that I want to find
and uh this is probably the most
important slide to the talk these are
the kinds of guarantees that we actually
get
Okay so
a safe action model is one where that
only allows the action to be taken if
you can be sure that
the precondition of the real action in
the real domain is satisfied
and if you can tell precisely what the
resulting state of the world will be
after executing that action
so it's a safety guarantee it just says
that the plan will execute and it will
execute the way you expect it to there's
a complimentary completeness guarantee
this is the part that's approximate and
probabilistic
it says okay well was probability one
minus Delta uh over the trading
trajectories I get an action model that
was probability one minus Epsilon over a
draw of a new problem from that
distribution
uh the action model is adequate it
contains a plan that gets me uh from the
start state to a goal state
um and so let me give you one more
example of a yeah sorry Mike
when you set the ballistic guarantee you
said with probability
but I thought you said the trajectories
don't come from
sorry it was probably one last episode
over the problems no problem okay you
get you you'll get some sort of set of
trajectories right the trajectories will
be for problems normally distribution
but
you know they say those the trajectories
in the example problems put the
adversary to think of it
other questions
is there any notion of like short plans
because yeah so we should we should
probably ideally have that here
and we can add it it won't cost you
anything
so it's not hard to extend this to the
short plans no no no right yeah and in
fact but we'll also get that
um well we could also get the plans the
model that you learn will contain plans
that are no longer than you know the
corresponding uh plans you can get as
the examples
I don't promise if you give me really
long plans for things that everybody
short plans that I can find in the
shortcuts
other questions
sure so just in terms of this safe
action
so in the case that you said where you
have let's say
a particular condition which holds
before and after an action of the same
condition
so you don't know whether that was if
that always was the case in all the
trajectories
right we said you don't know whether
this
right so what what is the
sort of get to say hey this is the way
out of that yeah yeah so
um the way it's going to work is that
the model is going to be conservative
and so in cases where you don't know
what the effect is going to be it will
prevent you from taking the action and
that'll you know
fold that into the print condition
yeah and that'll actually just come out
very nicely from some you know very
simple uh learning methods
but you know before I go there I wanted
to give you one more example that might
help motivate this problem to this crowd
which is that the action model is
basically a non-deterministic album
so here's a here's an example planning
domain right I've got fluence that
describe a configuration of my turing
machine
right so I and is an index into the tape
cells you know so I have a
predicate for you know the head being at
location I the symbol at I being Sigma
for each thing in the alphabet cell I is
adjacent to cell J and the machines in
state q for each you know whatever I
have big Q many states
so my actions uh I could have one action
for each symbol state and airity of the
the relation size right so the branching
of the factor of the non-deterministic
machine
where you know the pre um condition just
checks that I gave you the current
location of the head the correct symbol
at that location
right and I guess also should be the the
state of the machine uh and that J is as
appropriate the cell to the left or
right okay and then the effect would be
well the head moves from I to J so it's
not at I it's at J I wrote Sigma Prime
at I and
Sigma is no longer what was written at I
so then the planning problem is okay so
I have tape cells right one to
polynomially many
um my starting State just encodes X
followed by blanks on the tape
uh the starting state is the start State
for the machine and
cell I is before cell I plus one for all
I okay
so I find I want to get to just a state
where the turing machine accepts
so
um I've set this up so that a plan
exists precisely when the
non-deterministic turing machine accepts
X within that space
right
um and you know you can see the
trajectories are just these computation
histories for a given branch of the
non-determinism
right
um the non-determinism comes in this
choice of which action to apply
right
and the only part that depends on the
actual algorithm apart from say the
count of the uh symbols and uh internal
States is the action model
so learning the action model here really
is learning a non-deterministic
algorithm given example executions of
the algorithm
so yeah I mean also like planning is
piece based complete unless you bound
the length of the plan in which case
it's only NP complete and so planners
are solving these hard problems uh and
how they do it is not my business
but
yeah really what I want is
um to get some kind of an action model
that could hand off to your
non-deterministic machine and
um it will only accept things that are
in the language and it will accept
almost everything that's in the language
which respect to that Distribution on
inputs
okay okay
so maybe you feel more motivated I don't
know
all right let's move onward okay so
algorithms for basic strips models and
again of course that
that model is a strips model okay so
strips is also expressive enough to do
some interesting things
so yeah the way we do this is
um the strips axioms if you you know
flip them around give you some kind of
conservative learning rules okay so if I
know that the preconditions have to be
satisfied in the pre-state means that
literals that weren't satisfied in the
pre-state couldn't have been
preconditions
so I can start with all literals and I
can cross off the ones that aren't
preconditions right looking over the
trajectories
um now I know that the effects have to
be satisfied in the post state so
literals that weren't satisfied couldn't
have been effects I'm actually not going
to use this rule the one I'm really
going to use is the third one which I
can write as saying if there's a literal
that
um is satisfied in the post state but
not the pre-state that had to be in
effect right so if it switches on that
literal switches on that had to be an
effect of the action and that's really
the the one I'm going to use
today
um so like I'll start from all possible
preconditional literals and just cross
them off as I see them violated and I'll
start with no effects and add them as I
see things switch on when the action
gets taken
all right so yeah just you know as an
example like I start with this
trajectory and for this move a b action
I say well okay you know what are the
things that were true you know the truck
was at a the package was at C you know
maybe that's my precondition you know
that shouldn't be there and then this
and another observation if I see the
package someplace else here the package
wasn't it see so I cross off that
literal
do this for for all the actions I see in
these trajectories okay right so uh
thinking of States as sets of literals
and also preconditional sets of literals
right I can write the Learned
um precondition that I get just as this
intersection over the pre-states
and it's easy to see that the true
precondition
um is a subset of this right because
well the actual preconditions had to be
satisfied in all the pre-states for the
actions
um and likewise you know I'm going to
use this estimate the union of all the
things that switched on as my uh effect
set and the only things that um switch
on are effects so I know that it's a
subset of the possible effects okay
and so really the only concern here
um for safety
is whether or not or what happens for
the effects that I didn't see
now here look I mean either every effect
either is in every pre-state or was
missing from it one time okay if it was
ever missing uh you know wasn't true in
the priesthood I don't see it switch on
when I take the action so it gets
included as an effect
on the other hand if the literal was
always there in the pre-state it's going
to remain in my conservative
precondition
right and uh because these actions have
to be consistent somehow that is it
can't have both the literal and its
negation as an effect right that
wouldn't make sense that doesn't you
know that would give you some sort of
incoherent State
um because of that
the frame Axiom will guarantee that if
this literal was true in the pre-state
it remains true in the post state
okay so then regardless of whether or
not uh that was that literal was in
effect it's true in the post State and
the this conservative model will
correctly predict that that fluent is
present in the post state
okay so it's so it's safe in that you
know it's going to correctly get the set
of effects for the actions and the
preconditions will always be satisfied
[Music]
I think they can start that you could
only go from something being unset to
set known the other way around
um
so uh
you're saying is starting everything and
start and setting it do you also have
something for negations can something
that has been set become unserved no I
mean it's it goes in one direction right
so I start with all the Liberals in the
precondition I just cross them off as I
see things that would violate them and I
start with nothing in the effects and
then we add them to message
I don't switch them off right yeah
um and again like once I add them to the
effects set I only do that when I when
it had to have been an effective
reaction
this is a simple model
other questions
so
um it's safe and now we can also prove
this sample complexity level right so
given this number of trajectories uh you
know so it's scaling with one over
Epsilon for the uh probability of
solving new problems uh linear in number
of actions times number of fluids that's
actually the size of these grounded
action models plus log one over Delta
for the bad probability over the uh
training set
and yeah you can it's easy to see that
um the algorithm executed in time that
was linear above the input and output
and yeah the sample complexity is also
uh linear in the size of the action
model so that's good okay
yeah sorry Mike so the phrase permits
solving problem yeah the meaning of that
is that right so the action model
uh we'll specify that you know some set
of trajectories are are allowed right or
consistent with the strict Saxons
and what I mean is that there should be
a trajectory consistent with the axioms
that gets from the start state to the
goal state
in that problem
assuming the problem is so yeah that's
that's right
um and you know you can you can have
right so you could have a distribution
that includes you know unsolvable
problems is like no one's in central NTM
uh safety will guarantee that
no trajectory there would ever you know
accept right and so yeah you should you
should probably limit the length of the
search for in that case what we'll
guarantee is that you know on the subset
of the instances that are solvable the S
instances right we get at least the one
minus that's one fraction of those so
let's see
ensures that the set of trajectory is
the subset yes yes that's correct
yeah
okay
so we returned safety of this of this
method right so really all I need to
show is this completeness
um and informally we'll say that I'm
going to say that I'm going to specify
this more formal detail in 30 seconds
but uh an action model is adequate for
plans drawn through a distribution D if
with high probability the preconditions
allow executing that plan
and we'll show with high probability
this conservative action model algorithm
uh is adequate
so precisely
um for my set of learn preconditions
uh that that set of that action model is
Epsilon adequate
for this distribution over Planet
problems and trajectories if the
probability that the learn preconditions
don't hold for some action in uh the the
trajectory associated with that problem
is it most Epsilon
and we'll argue that action models that
aren't Epsilon adequate
can only be consistent with the
trajectories it's probability it's
exponentially small in the size of the
training set
and this is pretty simple
um right because we're just focusing on
these preconditions
okay if the action model was not Epsilon
adequate that means that uh there's some
action uh where I didn't see it observed
in this in this state that where the
precondition was violated
okay
um but by definition
right therefore uh it can only be
consistent you know if I miss that in
all of these M samples right and as each
one's independent so the probability
that that bad action model not
inadequate action model survives after
I'm examples this is why my steps one of
the m and okay that's that's the
expression
okay so that's pretty simple
um and now given that right we're just
doing the usual thing I'm just counting
the number of action models
and taking a union bound over them right
so the probability that
um the action model is consistent after
this many examples
is you know Delta divided by the count
of the number of action models so I can
afford to take a union bound over all
possible action models
okay so therefore was probability one
minus Delta only adequate action models
survive and the output of my algorithm
in particular must be adequate
so yeah it's it's a it's a standard
style learning theory argument and the
only difference was in um what are bad
events were
okay
so uh right that was all grounded right
so with with
um objects actually just Bound in
everywhere and it's important to talk
about lifted models because then you can
generalize to different size domains um
and they're also much more compact right
you know uh you know each lifted uh
fluent corresponds to a number of fluids
that's polynomial with the exponent
given by the arity of the the you know
influence right so it's important for us
to be able to learn these lifted
representations
um
and we'll do this under some uh
assumptions okay
so first of all as I said I'm going to
assume that the preconditions and
effects were bound to action parameters
and in particular and assume that I get
trajectories where the bindings are
unique that is the same object is not
bound to due to two different parameters
of the action
this is an injective binding assumption
and
in most cases this is true just because
like you get some sort of a trivial
no-op
but if you if you bound the same thing
right like in the in the logistics
domain uh in the turing machine domain
like you know the same cell was not
adjacent to itself right
um there are things you can do without
the injective binding assumption but it
gets a little ugly so I'm going to skip
it for today
uh you can look at the paper if you want
to know but
once you have this injective binding
assumption it's not hard because you can
you can directly read off from the
trajectory right like what what should
be that parameter action parameter
so what we do is uh we're just we're
just applying the same rules okay but
then converting the
um grounded literals back to the
literals in terms of the action
parameters where we actually record what
are the preconditions and effects
so yeah to be concrete okay in this move
um example right and if I have moved
truck a b
um then only the literals that are bound
to these parameters are relevant right
so only these black literals all the
other green ones have state C or the
package in them so you know they're not
relevant here
and if I look at what happens on these
these black literals right you know
maybe initially I had the empty set of
effects and you know I had these effects
on
um the object X being it you know State
y or Z
okay then my my you know because those
are the two locations the one object I
can talk about
after I see this effect of the move
action right I see okay well initially
you know the truck was at a and not B so
I can cross off these literals about
um you know X not being at Y and X being
at Z
you know because like I know that I can
substitute X for truck and Y for a and z
for B
right so I just map them back to these
lifted literals and then I can do the
learning as before
ditto with B with the effects
so there's nothing very complicated
there
all right
so let's get to some basic learning
theory questions
right uh you know how rich a family of
action models can be learned in
particular for preconditions and effects
what can I learn safely efficiently uh
we have some work on learning
probabilistic effects I won't talk about
it today and some other things I also
won't talk about today about other
observation models like partial
information
okay
um so for preconditions the first
observation is that I can reduce
supervised learning from positive
examples for a class
to Safe action model learning with
preconditions from that class
um it's it's relatively straightforward
right I just have this set of um you
know examples where I just start in some
state that I want to know uh the label
of right and some action gets taken
there
and because the um the model has to
learn safe preconditions just from these
positive examples
right uh whatever precondition
representation it produces for you
will only allow uh sorry can only allow
that that pre that action to be taken uh
in cases where the precondition would be
satisfied right that is I got the set of
positive examples and I get a
representation that is only true
um for positive examples
it's often able to do that you know for
high with high probability is
appropriate then
uh you know for like a one minus Epsilon
fraction of the positive examples then
that was a a Learner in this positive
example only learning
and that was studied extensively in the
early days of learning theory right in
particular natarajan you know observed
that the optimal safe concept is just
the intersection of all consistent
Concepts
so for example if uh I'm trying to learn
half spaces right the best thing you can
do is look at the convex Hall of the
data
um and in particular right an early
observation was that disjunctions are
not learnable because for any say input
that I haven't seen before it's going to
be consistent with the disjunction that
says oh not that point
right so the intersection of not that
point for everything I haven't seen
before well is just the set of points
that I have seen before right so in this
setting learner just memorizes and can
never generalize
okay
so how
pushed the preconditions right given
this knowledge uh well access align
boxes are learnable right if I just look
at the Min and max value of each
coordinate that's definitely the
intersection of all the access align
boxes
okay
um and you know and you can argue that
that generalizes appropriately
uh unfortunately you can't do much more
than that right so Goldberg observed
that even in dimension two half spaces
are not learnable right because like if
my data lies on this circle okay uh that
convex hall right is just tangent to The
Circle at each of those points and so
I'm just memorizing points on the circle
right anything I haven't seen like could
be where that half space cuts off okay
so again you just memorize
um and it's either impossible to learn
or takes an exponential number of
examples
showed that complements and unions of
intervals in one dimension are not
learnable for basically a similar reason
right I see these points on the line and
anywhere there's a gap that could be
where that forbidden interval lies
so again you don't generalize
um you're just memorizing points on the
distribution
okay so that
basically closes like what you can hope
to learn
um you know in terms of preconditions
so what about what about effects uh well
one thing I can say is that even if I
allow some uh error like in a numeric
setting if I allow some numerical error
in in predicting the post State I can
reduce approximate interpolation for C
to the safe action model learning
problem with effects from C right
um okay what is approximate
interpolation well basically I should
satisfy this condition
right I want to I want a uniform bound
on the infinity Norm of the true
function and the thing that I learned
okay and so you know naturally
uh the sample complexity of this problem
is given by the VC dimension of this
class right indicating when I would uh
violate that uniform interpolation
property
and so uh in particular right that you
know that VC dimension of this class
gives me this sample complexity lower
bound
um and in the case of say Boolean
functions uh this thing is actually just
collapsing to the VC dimension of the
function class
um now I mean so this tells me a lot
about like what classes are not
learnable right because if they have a
high VC Dimension or infinite DC
Dimension then I can't learn them or I
can't learn them efficiently
um it's still open like exactly what uh
condition gives you safe uh action model
learning in general simply because as
we've seen and we'll see further right
it depends on the interaction between
the preconditions and the effects
but anyway
um so so what's the most General thing I
know how to learn
uh well okay supposing for a minute that
the observations are errorless then I
can learn action models where
preconditions are conjunctions of
intervals with linear equality
constraints
and the effects are affine functions
um and the algorithm well I mean I do
the obvious thing for the intervals and
separately I just write a Subspace
containing all the pre-states as a set
of linear constraints
and then I solve for the outline effects
on that Subspace and note that the data
has full rank on the Subspace it spans
right so I can actually solve for that
set of atfin effects
okay it's safe because on the one hand
for sure
um the interval that I learned while
those were you know things that were
within whatever bounds are the
preconditions
and subspaces are closed under span so
therefore the true Subspace must be in
um must contain the span of The observed
data
so I'd say preconditions
and then this observation about the data
having full rank on its span tells me
that okay that affine transformation is
uniquely determined uh on that Subspace
right that the the pre-states are
guaranteed to lie
so therefore I get safety right that
affine transformation is is just
uniquely determined okay
so that's a safe action model
um and completeness well you know I can
bound the VC Dimension uh of of the
preconditions and effects right
and so yeah so it basically follows
um
that uh you know from these like
standard BC Dimension bounds that okay
the um
for sufficiently large set of
preconditions
uh anything that was was consistent with
all those preconditions is going to be
you know adequate with this probability
okay so that's enough to get my my
completeness guarantee
I'm skipping some details here but it's
very similar to what we did in the first
thing it's pretty standard okay
um let me just very briefly talk about
conditional effects okay so back in
Boolean domains
um
previously the actions had preconditions
and the effects were literals
the initial effect is a little richer
right it's it's given by a pair there's
some sort of a condition for the effect
that's given by a conjunction
and
the interpretation is uh that
the literal only becomes satisfied in
the post state
if the condition was satisfied with the
conditional effect right
if there's some literal in the pre-state
that wasn't the effect of some uh
conditional effect with the satisfied
condition it Remains the Same okay so
it's just a switch on each of the
effects now
um right now let's look at the
complexity of the problem of learning an
action model when there are conditional
effects
and it turns out that actually it's a
lot it's a lot harder
um
so you know again I've got the set of uh
I got this distribution right on
problems uh actions a influence F and
suppose the conditional effects have
size up to K
okay some some parameter here
um and now if I'm getting what's
probability at least four minus Delta a
safe action model that's containing
solutions to the problems as probability
of these four minus Epsilon then I
needed at least this many uh examples
that is in particular exponential
in the uh well sorry exponential in the
size of those those conditions for the
conditional effects
uh so you know if I don't limit the size
of those conditional effects then this
ends up being you know exponential in
the domain description size
so I can only hope to give you an
efficient method uh if say I've
restricted this to be some kind of a
constant
so uh I probably don't have a lot of
time for the proof of this
um so let me just skip it
but yeah
uh you can ask me about it if you're
interested
let's just look at the the the algorithm
okay so I'm going to be able to learn
um with this sample complexity right so
it's similar to the or essentially
optimal
I I you know I had uh for for conditions
of size k
I had this uh you know eight times F
times something that's like f to the k
so it has optimal sample complexity for
a fixed uh precondition size
um and the other interesting thing to
know here is that
okay it's you know I'm allowing the
preconditions to be a K plus 1 C and F
now right so not just a set of literals
I have a set of Clauses of width up to K
plus one but it's returning for me a set
of a precondition with uh causes of size
up to K plus two and I dropped that
limit on the size of the conditions for
the conditional effects right so this is
a kind of an improper
learning algorithm for this this uh
model and maybe we can see why that's
appropriate
so what we're going to do is we're going
to track for each action
the Clauses that might be preconditions
this is just some generalization of
tracking the literals that could have
been preconditions
um and for each candidate effect literal
the with K Clauses that were true
whenever the effect occurred and those
were false whenever the effect failed to
occur right
so these are the things that could
possibly still be conditions for that
anything else must not be
uh and the action is safe for all
candidate conditional effects if either
um okay so the effect literal was
already satisfied in the pre-state and
then I don't care whether or not it's
conditional effect
or all the remaining candidate Clauses
are false right in which case
I know that it must not be an effect or
all the remaining candidate Clauses are
true and therefore no matter which one
actually was a condition uh the effect
occurs right and if I look at the
um these these conditions this
corresponds to a big conjunction this
corresponds to a big case unit
so I can rewrite this condition as a K
plus 2 C and F just by Distributing
over the um you know so I have these The
Ore of these three things and then I
just distribute over the big or in the
um the CNF here
so
um I'm going to give you a precondition
for the action that's given by that K
plus 2 cmf and all the K plus 1 with
Clauses uh surviving that could still be
the actual preconditions
and the effect literal is going to be
given by a conditional effect where the
condition is the conjunction of all
those remaining possible uh
conditions
so it's safe because uh well for sure I
included all the true precondition
causes right just like before
and I know that uh this CNF ensures that
whether or not the uh effect occurs is
determined on anything that's going to
pass this condition
so indeed
um I'm only going to allow actions that
actually execute and I'm only going to
allow them in cases where for every
literal I know whether or not it's true
in the post state
for the sample complexity
um now we're going to just track the
state of the data structure
uh that's that's you know keeping track
of what Clauses could be conditions or
not
if the corresponding precondition wasn't
one minus Epsilon adequate then was
probability at least Epsilon the
trajectory contained a state in which
one of these things was violated either
some extraneous precondition was
falsified or some but not all of the
candidate conditions were false right so
that that CNF for
being able to determine the
um effect of the action right whether or
not the conditional effect occurred
right that thing was violated
um and either the the effect actually
would be observed to occur or would not
be observed to occur
uh and basically in each case uh some
Clause is deleted right either I get rid
of that precondition or
um those Clauses that were false when
the effect would occur right those
couldn't have been the conditions for
that literal
or these Clauses that were true when the
effect didn't occur also couldn't have
been preconditions for conditions for
that for that conditional effect
so no matter which one happens a clause
gets deleted and the data structure
can't be in that state afterwards okay
so again like like before uh right with
so with with probability
um
if the thing if the data structure gives
you an action model that's not Epsilon
adequate it only survives with
probability at most one minus Epsilon
and then after M trajectories decreases
exponentially so again we just count and
take a union bound
okay
so just to wrap up all right we were
learning a safe planning model by
learning a conservative action model
and we get a safe efficient and
approximately complete learning for
these relational strips models the
strips models with conditional effects
of small size and these numeric models
with affine effects and this
intersection of interval and Subspace
preconditions
um we're working on learning more
General types of stochastic domains uh
also there was a work on stochastic
domains that I didn't talk about at all
we have some work on learning from
partial observations and we are
continuing to work on learning in these
continuous State spaces actions with
duration and so on all right uh that's
all I have
um
any questions
I was wondering does your algorithm give
some guarantee of minimality in a
certain sense of what you're learning
[Music]
well I mean so Marco had that nice
question about the plan length and it's
it's not hard to see that because in
particular we're ensuring that
the action model allows the trajectory
associated with each of the actions with
that probability
um it's allowing you to find plans that
are no longer than
uh whatever you know appears in those
training examples and you know whatever
you know this is some adversarial
function that Maps is problems to
examples uh we're going to guarantee
that we get plans that are longer from
those now otherwise you know regarding
like
the count of the like literals in the
model or something like this well like
is it the most compact representation of
the world as you've seen it during
learning question in general no
um
right to me
yeah so like for example these
preconditions
may contain extraneous Littles I mean in
fact like look I mean I could always
delete all the all the preconditions but
that wouldn't be saved
uh whether or not
hey
that's the safest or the the most
compact thing that um is safe
I guess yeah okay I mean again assuming
that it's of this form I guess the
answer should be yes
um because
right I need the intersection of all the
consistent
uh action models right and
um
Yeah so basically
right the only things that got ruled out
were violated literals
okay so therefore that
um
safe model right can only delete the
literals that were violated right if it
deletes anything else it's not safe
so then yeah I mean I need all the
literals in that
um
action model that I returned in order to
be energy safety so in that sense yeah
and and I guess ditto for the effects in
that basic script smoke right I needed
to have all those effects
in order to guarantee safety right yes
so yeah I mean you know but it's such a
simple representation right you know you
can start to see that that I get things
that are not minimal like if you if you
were to try to learn to have space
that's right because then the convex
Hall the data
um you know in general can have like
exponentially many faces even if there
was just that one half space that you
know would have been correct
other questions
okay
yes